playstation 5 isn't just a stylish
looking console
it also packs a lot of pretty sweet new
features here are seven of the newest
and coolest things the ps5
is bringing to this generation of gaming
number seven haptic feedback
the days of just a controller shaking
for the sake of shaking in your hands is
over the dual sense is taking rumble one
step further with its heptic feedback
this feature allows you to feel
different sensations and surfaces like
the rolling thunder in the distance and
the kickback from a gun or
a fart who knows imagination is the
limit developers like insomniac are
taking advantage of it for
marvel's spider-man miles morales so
when you use the venom punch you'll feel
spidey's bioelectricity crackle from one
side of the controller to the other
number six adaptive triggers another
feature of the new dualsense controller
is
its adaptive triggers the l2 and r2
triggers now feature dynamic resistance
levels so
say you run out of ammo the trigger can
lock in place until you reload
or feeling the sensation of pulling back
on a bow
because i want nothing more than the
field like a more in the last of us part
two
number five 3d audio sure feeling is one
thing but sony is taking immersion one
step further with its tempest 3d audio
tech
using accessories like the ps5 pulse 3d
wireless headset
it'll be taking advantage of simulating
surroundings of your game in rich 3d
audio goodness
and engrossing you in it full force for
games like resident evil village
the developers are designing its horror
with spatial audio in mind
so now you can hear the groans growl
screams and blood splatter of demon
souls as
though you're really there absolutely
terrifying i love it
number four faster load times loading
screens have been a burden to gaming
since their conception but no more
to an extent the ps5 is taking full
advantage of solid state drives reducing
load times
and getting you into games a whole lot
faster with games like ratchet and clank
rift apart
showing it off full force this means
less scrolling through reddit to pass
time and more immersion in games
now long loading screens are lost to
nostalgia a thing to tell your children
about
until they stop listening to you and
force you to go back to bed
number three vertical horizontal stand
and removable panels
love it or hate it the ps5 certainly
stands out and despite its obtuse design
it can in fact stand tall or lay
horizontally thanks to its nifty stand
also the panels are removable paving the
way to some sweet customized panels
to come and even cooler there's also a
dust catcher vent
that you can use to vacuum away the dust
pretty sweet
number two game boost and backwards
compatibility worry not
your favorite playstation games of
yesteryear aren't being left behind
not only will 99 of ps4 games work on
the ps5
that figure courtesy of playstation ceo
jim ryan
but the newest member of the playstation
family is also giving select ps4
and psvr games a bit of a facelift with
fast and smooth frame rates
if you're subscribed to ps plus you get
some of those classic ps4 games for free
as a part of your subscription the
selection of freebie games includes
bloodborne god of war and uncharted 4.
play bloodborne number one cooling
any ps4 owner should know a little too
well
the beautiful screaming sound of the
console's fan going in overdrive
for the ps5 however not only does it
come with a chunk of a fan meant for
drawing in lots of air
it also has a super sleek dope copper
cooling system
and even liquid metal for long-term
cooling performance
putting the cool and this being a cool
feature for the
cool ps5 okay yeah and there you have it
some of the coolest ps5 features thanks
for watching for more playstation past
present and future keep your eyes on
gamespot and while you're at it
check out the show generation next it's
the show about
next generation consoles alright thanks
again see ya
you